Details, die anmuten, als stammen
sie aus der Vorkriegszeit.
Doch dies ist kein gut
gewarteter Auto-Klassiker.
Es ist ein Seifenkisten-Oldtimer
- Baujahr 2017 -
und gehört den beiden Schwestern
Julia und Carlotta Haas.
Wir finden‘s einfach cool, wenn wir
einfach als Kinder auch schon ‘n Auto,
ich sag jetzt mal, ‘n kleines Auto,
aber ‘n Auto fahren dürfen
und es macht einfach Spaß.
Also ich finde es auch so toll,
weil es macht auch Spaß,
und es ist auch immer aufs
Neue wieder ein Erlebnis.
Vor allem, weil diese Seifenkiste
einen Motor besitzt.
Der Zweisitzer der beiden Mädchen
ist ein handgemachtes, exklusives Unikat.
Er ähnelt dem englischen
Vorkriegsrennwagen  „Lagonda Rapier“
und ist so etwas wie Papas Traumwagen.
Papa ist großer Oldtimer-Fan.
Er wünscht sich, dass Julia und Carlotta
seine automobile Leidenschaft übernehmen.
Meine Hoffnung ist groß,
und ich nehme meine Töchter ja
auch häufig mit zum Nürburgring,
auf … zu Oldtimer-Rennen, nehme auch
teilweise an Oldtimer-Rallyes
zusammen mit meiner Frau und mir teil.
Und ich bin zuversichtlich, dass das klappt
und dass sie das Hobby des Vaters
auch zukünftig annehmen werden.
Das ist der Mann, der die
Edel-Seifenkisten konstruiert:
Frank Bankonin aus dem schwäbischen Biburg.
Reich wird er mit seiner Manufaktur nicht,
aber darum geht es ihm auch nicht.
Sondern um strahlende Kinderaugen.
Also wenn ich sowas sehe, dann ... dass
dann bin ich richtig happy, weil dafür
sind die Autos ja eigentlich gemacht.
Ich mein‘, ich fahr' sie selber auch gerne,
aber wenn Kinder damit fahren und damit
klarkommen und da richtig Spaß dran haben,
dann ist das für mich die größte Freude.
Damit hat 2012 alles angefangen.
Im Dorf von Frank Bankonin fand ein
Seifenkisten-Rennen statt.
Da er seit seinem 16. Lebensjahr
an Fahrzeugen schraubt,
baute er sich kurzerhand
dieses Renngefährt.
Aus Platzgründen verkaufte
er es anschließend.
Der Andrang war groß, und so wurde
der Seifenkistenbau sein großes Hobby.
Ich liebe Vorkriegsautos aller Art,
egal, sind alle schön.
Es gibt keine Favoriten. Ich mag jedes
Auto gleich gern von mir.
Mittlerweile hat sich der
Außenhandelsvertreter mit den Flitzern
im Oldtimer-Look einen Namen gemacht.
Ich hab 'ne gewisse
Grundvorstellung im Kopf,
und dann fang' ich einfach an zu bauen,
und das
[er]gibt sich einfach. Es, es [er]gibt sich
… es entwickelt sich einfach beim Bauen.
Es gibt da kein festes Konzept.
Ich weiß, wie das Auto im Endeffekt
ausschauen muss im Kopf,
und dann schaue ich,
dass es genauso wird.
Jede seiner Seifenkisten ist ein Unikat.
Die Basis ist immer eine Holzplatte,
auf die ein Holzgerippe geleimt
und verschraubt wird.
Anschließend fertigt er, je nach
Fahrzeugtyp, die Alukarosserie
- wochenlang, teilweise monatelang.
Schmerzt da die Trennung von
seinen fahrenden Kunstwerken?
Doch, jedes Mal. Jedes Mal!
Aber das Problem ist: Ich kann nicht alles,
ich kann nicht alles aufheben.
Man muss sich dann irgendwann
auch mal davon trennen.
Ob er wohl bleiben darf?
Frank Bankonin hat diesen echten Oldtimer
komplett neu aufgebaut.
Es gab nur noch das Fahrgestell
und den Motor des englischen „Standard“
aus dem Jahr 1930.
Auch für Christian Haas hat er etwas
ganz Spezielles gebaut:
eine Seifenkiste zum Rennen üben.
Die Idee war, dass ich nicht einen
Sitz haben wollte,
sondern das Feeling wirklich auch
hier in der Halle spüren wollte.
Und der Wagen ist wunderschön geworden.
Er hat natürlich keine Räder,
sondern läuft auf Rollen.
Aber er hilft mir sehr,
(für) die Rundstreckenrennen zu üben.
Eigene Rennen fahren, das liegt für
seine Töchter – 10 und 11 Jahre alt –
noch in weiter Ferne.
Im Moment geht es darum, wann sie
welche der drei Seifenkisten steuern.
Ob die beiden auch, wenn sie älter werden,
noch wie der Papa Benzin im Blut haben,
wird sich zeigen.
Aber man sieht schon jetzt:
Der Apfel fällt nicht weit vom Stamm.